japan is famous for their convenience
lawson 7-eleven family mart
what's the other one called
mini stop daily yamasaki as a new
resident of japan tokyo everything is
new to me
my mission is to find the best
japanese snack cut to lost on pewdiepie
yeah
why would you do that japan
[Music]
[Music]
i got a similar one
[Music]
[Music]
all right we got the goods now back to
kitchen feelings kitchen felix here
thank you receipt pewdiepie but where
are my snacks
what
so many snacks wow
but which one is the best one
we got a wide variety of the classics
and over here we have the weird corner
saving the best for last i think
is that a snack
or is that just a thing
why is this a thing
but it could be the greatest snack of
all all right let's dig in
what should i start with
we have martha's favorite
starving mice's favorite i know what i
want to start
with the pizza bun
[Music]
so you can get some hot food in there
and i always see them but i'm like
[Applause]
it's got that mcdonald's
gunkiness to it when it's been hot food
sitting for a while
that's good
that's actually good
hmm
[Music]
i can see myself ordering this three out
of five
we got to keep moving
i don't know what to get
why don't we start with do this cranky
are crunky japan's greatest snack
i'm about to find out
oh it's strawberry
these are crunky or good
i crunk it up
strawberry chocolate with a crunch to it
a crunchy to it
crunky gags are four out of five good
job crunky
give her up the crunky king
[ __ ] stays
270 percent
cranky wins over these these are three
out of five
you know
why japan have you done this
why put spaghetti
in a hot bun
this means a lot of people buy this
the smell
oh that's bad that's not good
huh
it's pretty good
yeah
you can never go wrong with carbs on
carbs that strangely works
well done japan if you're a vegetarian i
guess
here's your veggie sausage
actually that's actually good
it smelled like it's been sitting there
for a while but three and a half stars
to the weird sausage thing choco balls
i assume these are for children
but everyone whoa oh okay
it's got a little smart open
oh yeah
will they be crunky
[Music]
or peanuts
i don't like peanuts
overrated flavor
they belong to children
[Applause]
two stars
crunchy is better give me another crunky
cronkites are good
but speaking of crunk
what the hell is this
big katsu big katsu
it's so big it has to be said twice
so tasty
oh
strong flavor
oh we're so chewy
what am i eating right now
sauce flavor
nah they're saying it i think it's just
the fried part of a the fried chicken
but there's no chicken
it's just frying
this feels like it should be in america
two out of five this is garbage
so far the winner is crunky and i'm
extremely disappointed i want the most
delicious snack
it's hiding here somewhere i know it but
before i try anything else check out a
new sponsor segment exciting pewdiepie
announcement new rhino shield pewdiepie
phone cases
yeah
these are the most durable phone cases
i've ever used just chunk them on your
phone and you don't have to worry about
it it's always so fun seeing you guys
showing these off whenever i meet you
you know it's not required but it's
it's kind of epic
we have five new pewdiepie japanese
inspired designs i'm really happy how
these turn out i think this is one is my
favorite we got the torii gate
we got the drank
we got the tokyo knights kombini version
and the sexy ramen shop we also brought
back some of the classic designs like
the classic wave my dad loves to use
this one
but the most exciting part of this claim
we now have
grips
[Music]
these are so good i saw them advertise
this i was hoping we would do them for
me as well you just simply attach them
to your phone case and bam never again
will this happen to you
they sort of press to your hand so you
get a nice tight thing it's great for
when you're out and about walking around
making sure you don't drop your phone
even if you did it would be fine
it's also great for taking selfies
but the best part
this comes out it turns your phone into
the perfect vertical and horizontal
stand this is amazing for me because i
always vlog on my phone so to have a
tripod on the sand is so good they have
the grip max and the grip mini and don't
worry they have a magsafe version of
these as well they're made from 85
recycled plastic which i really
appreciate thank you rhinoshield for
always being responsible if you order
any of the pewdiepie designs you get a
pewdiepie fiber cloth for free
you're welcome obviously you also need a
screen protector to protect your screen
itself it's super easy to attach anyone
can do it and they also had what kind of
blew my mind a privacy screen which i've
always wanted it you can use it on the
subway or whatever and no one can see
what you're doing
you're not doing anything bad are you
i don't know i don't like people looking
at my memes sue me so use the link in
the description and you will get 20 off
for a limited time this is unlimited to
the first week so make sure you order
now to get the 20 off deal definitely
take advantage of that use the code
pewdiepie to get the 20 off and if you
happen to be a little slow that's fine
you will still get 10 percent off but
that's it check it out take advantage of
the code and i mean definitely check out
the pewdiepie ones super happy with
these show off your grip greatness and
use the link in the description thank
you rhinoshield for sponsoring this
video i hope you guys will like these as
well
wow what a great sponsor segment all
right let's keep eating
these are cool by the way
i do this
i eat this now
cute packaging
cute product
i feel like this is the kind of thing
japanese school girls buy on their way
home from school
and you know what i respect them for it
these are good 3.4
pretty good
i refuse to believe crunchy is the best
snack out of me it's not happening
but
okay what is this purple
[Applause]
all right all right toppo what you got
these look like the thing you put on ice
creams like the cigars
they're like
the typical sticks but with the
chocolate on the inside it's pretty good
it's pretty also pretty boring who would
buy this old people why does this come
up
oh secret compartment open both ways
that's pretty exciting but i guess
another point
two
boring
should i do one of the weird stuff i'll
do one in the weird dried salmon is that
the greatest snack in japan
i'm about to find out
oh i wish i didn't do that
hmm
that's pretty good
hey
it's very salty
hmm
nah two out of five just eat salmon i
don't want a dry salmon
oh god that's flavor is so overpowering
oh god that makes me think what the [ __ ]
is this gonna be
i don't wanna think about that right now
all right speaking of which yogurt taste
soda
looks kind of like meat isn't it
ew
the salmon just went down to one
mmm
all right
aesthetic packaging great flavor
it's carbonated 250 calories
for a drink nah i say nah i guess two
everything gets two everything's japan
has really let me down
come on
oh marta would love this it's a pizza
flavor
[Applause]
pizza look they even got the italian
flag
smells like pizza
we just beat crunky
[Applause]
new champion
four out of five that's pretty good
pizza potato who would have thought the
new champion of japan
they're so thin and crusty i'm gonna put
it here as the new champion
will it get knocked out who knows
perhaps by this funny packaging
hilarious it's an onion
but are you stronger than the wait what
the
they look like this
that's very oniony
oh very chewy
very goody
[Applause]
they're good
3.4 does not beat the pizza pizza's
master all right
another gross one oh god
who knows maybe boiled in season quailed
eggs
what is quail is that a fish
what's up
do you know what a coil is
[Music]
it's a bird oh they're bigger than i
thought
oh
[Applause]
god damn
[Applause]
i hate eggs
i'm a retired youtuber okay i don't eat
weird stuff anymore
what
that's good
all right goes to show don't knock until
you try it better than the salmon i'll
give it 2.5
i'm still a little grossed out by it but
it was a really nice flavor
pizza supreme
pizza supreme pizza supreme
who will knock out the pizza
perhaps these i had these before
actually they're uh
shrimp flavored chips it doesn't sound
good
got a cute little
why is there a duck on the front
they smell horrible
but you know what
they're pretty damn good
very light crunch i like that
it doesn't taste that much actually
yeah i'm a little disappointed it
doesn't taste that much
yeah they're kind of
they kind of just kind of dry and
not much flavor
the shrimp flavor is really light i
think if i gave this to someone and
didn't say it was shrimp
they probably wouldn't even notice
and why would you put shrimp on a potato
chip huh
i was disappointed two out of five
and disappointed gave a stick of
disappointment all right let's keep
going with that oh these i bought two
all right well
if you're ever in japan which one of the
rice i mean the which one of the shrimp
flavored chips should you get let's try
it out apparently i bought two
i think they're exactly the same
well i don't know
they're not bad
they're very easily digestible you know
i'll give it 2.9
pickled plum maybe pickle plum greatest
snack in japan
oh why do they look so gross they look
so much better on the photo
mama oh that's a strong sour flavor
sniff what is it called sniff
smell
i'm losing all languages guys
oh
i thought it would be soft
no there's no way no one eats this
oh
why why would you eat this
this offends me
oh but only 15 calories ah
[Applause]
that's bad
oh it's so sour and sweet at the same
time how does that work
can you tell by my face how much i love
it
[Music]
a new champion
nah
why would you do that
i don't get it
all right i need something good this
is marcia's holy
grail
what is it choco pan yeah choco pie
she always gets it she makes me
stop at any lawson there is because they
only sell them at lawson or at least the
ones she likes
it smells really nice i never realized
she's been talking about this for years
when we couldn't move to japan how much
she wanted her choco pun
that's good
i'm so soft and doughy
[Music]
i
[Music]
how do you eat a hole of this and don't
feel stomach pain
yeah yeah it just feels like it would
sit in my stomach if i ate the whole
thing
i give it a
i'll give it a 4 out of 5. that's really
good
it's a little clumsy to eat which i
don't like i mean i did remove the whole
thing but hey guys
this video is not about you
i think we're about halfway done and so
far
we have a champion
but there must be a stronger
contestant somewhere here i know it what
should i do next these i always see corn
potage corn potage it's
what's a corn plotted pottage
umai delicious okay
ah
a what
oh this is like a little mini snack for
kids
[Music]
no
no
no i'm rating it no i mean it said it
was corn potato but it definitely tasted
like corn
you want it
you want this
you like corn
it's too corny
you like it she loves it
unbelievable
all right
you heard corn and she suddenly came in
sleep on all these other snacks
all right what
what's this pie
it's something pie related they look
cute
maybe it's good
chocolate pie okay oh they're tiny
so cute wow
it's kind of like croissant texture they
make it seem like it's got so much cream
in it but i can barely taste it at all
it's like really dry yeah the after
flavor i can kind of taste him it's
pretty good actually
i don't hate it
i i'm already bored and i had one
sorry squirrel pie 2.9
i'm a harsh critic okay
japanese people don't cry
how is this the best one this cannot
what about this
it's a dry ice cream
is that it might just pick this one
how do i even open it
ah
[Applause]
this feels like the astronaut food like
when you get astronaut ice cream and
then
why would you do this
you have a fridge
come on
ill
it's all bubbly
why would you do this
i don't get it
you want to try it
it makes no sense oh my god you like it
stop
it's got chocolate in the middle
all right well my science enjoying it
what would you rate it
three you're harder creative than i am
well i'll give it one minute just get an
ice cream please
unless there's some weird vegan reason
keep it in 29 degrees celsius that's
pretty hard
all right a real ice cream
for real man
yes
i like this type of ice cream because
you can hold it
no problem
hey
hey he wants them
that's good
oh my god
yes
stop cringing you're just judging me
let me go ahead
but i got a plate
hey everyone
hey
new champion
[Music]
the new champion
everyone say hello the new champion what
was it called john paul could that be it
jampo jumbo jumbo yeah like jimbo jumbo
new supreme
i pet him
glory
4.5
5.5 delicious love it
this is what is this
japan has figured out how to make things
soft
everything you get is
you see that you squeeze it you get a
little piece
a little something oh
everything is so soft no matter what it
is
whoa that's very cool darby good
what flavor is it
i don't know what what flavor do you
think is it you want some monkey
you want some egging
melon that's it it's melon flavor it
doesn't say soup cake just melon
this shouldn't work but it's pretty good
it's not really my thing
you can though it
anyway chocolate pan 2.0 though
i said you've never tried these
you have she said she had never tried it
you have never tried it it's choco pan
but with creaming
that's good
why wouldn't you not prefer this the
pure your purees chocobo impurities
there's something sketchy about that
cream though i don't trust that cream
you know what i mean no i agree regular
chocolate pan batter
two two i guess two
we have spicy grilled and dried squid
legs
[Music]
oh oh
oh
my god is not going to kiss me ever
again
your face
i've had these
they're not bad
oh
that's really chewy
it's kind of
like jerky a little bit but seafoody
i've had better ones this one wasn't
that good
it's better than the salmon
so i guess i gave it 2.1 it's not that
bad
try it out maybe you like it
don't sleep on the dried squid that's
all i'm gonna say this
ho ho
so good
which one was the worst one so far
this is a loser you go in the shame
corner
the pickled plum was disgusting
i never thought i would prefer quail egg
over pickled plum but here i am jumbo
supreme
beta pickled plum
we got more
i don't know what it's called japanese
nerds tell me
uh oh gelatin
oh they smell amazing
this is such a distinct flavor i almost
feel nostalgic even though i have never
experienced the nostalgia part does that
make sense
if a child can open this i can open this
what are you doing are you taking the
potty
that's fine i hate pudding putting salt
putting room in my lime
oh my god how do i peel it off i might
just eat it with the plastic
is that bad
you want it is it for me
at least suck
one
poor japanese children if this is the
snack you get you get your corn crunch
and your bad gel go back into the show
you're bad gelatin i'm so sorry japanese
children
for your pain you better have pickled
plum that all right i'm gonna eat
pudding
why it's so wobbly
is it
is it solid is it liquid
what is it
i can't tell
so you put it upside down
and then you're supposed to
peel
press
pull
whoa
that was cool i flicked the little thing
and the whole thing fell
wow
that's already oh
my god
ah i don't i don't get pudding
i don't
jelly in general oh my god it's gonna
don't run away from me
hey
he's trying to escape
all right take two
no it's not five stars stop it
i don't get it pudding
is too weird it weirds me out i'm sorry
pudding fans
might say you can enjoy
it going to spell it you're going to
spill it stop it
jumbo supreme i need to know what i'm
eating
you look so sad about your pudding
i'm walking away in pain
is
japanese sweet potato is the greatest
snack in japan
these are actually not bad
looks like they dipped them in sugar i
think something sugary
yeah definitely 2.5 nothing to write
home about
you know what i mean
jumbo supreme
shane pickle plum
oh is this mochi oh we got mochi nice i
love mashi
myself would always get it in other
countries and i always feel like
ah look how soft there is
they are this like
insanely soft
i'm not sure exactly but apparently a
lot of old people die from eating machi
in japan because they're such thick
thing like they choke on them
oh that's good
that's good i love musket
these are great
they got jelly inside
oh
no
3.5 that's pretty good very jumbo
[Music]
rico
monster strike
okay
[Music]
these are pretty good
they taste like pizza
pizza flavor
[Music]
what is it what am i eating
[Music]
no
could it be
jumbo
jumbo no
new supreme
yeah
sorry jumbo cry about it
new supreme
you're supreme these are awesome
i don't know what it is though
do you know what it is these are the
ones we usually get
these are good too i don't know how they
do it
they're kind of like vegetable flavors
do you think that you're eating
something healthy
yeah i'm eating vegetables
that's really good i actually prefer
this
so
all right that's my stamp so you
literally bought it for yourself
i really thought jumbo was going to make
it to the end
another shrimp snack
these are better than the
than these
these aren't good
same company
they're really thin
i like it nice texture
four out of five i like these
these are good
you always see this in like japanese
nuts mix that you always find
these are awesome
i think it's yuzu and chili
[Applause]
yeah use it i'll definitely buy these
again
they're really spicy too
that citrusy goes well with the chili
i like it
only 200 calories that's not bad i love
them but they ain't supreme they go
behind
vice supreme
these are called
is that italian pino
what does it mean
pine tree
oh no pino no
pino no mamma mia
they all died
is it that hot out
damn
oh it's a slaughterhouse the whole
family died
sorry pino
you're not supreme
weak chocolate
all right
crunky
will crunky make it
to the final
that's an extra crunchy crunching you
got to try the crunchy man
i like the crunky they're cookie player
they're good right crunky don't sleep on
the crunky i'm going to put it next to
vice president supreme leader mike i out
these because they look cute what are
they why are they soft oh it's candy
what is that funny
oh i bought it what are you gonna do but
sorry
oh
they're good
oh
i don't know if i should chew on them or
suck on them
they're weird
they're milky
just as advertised
if you chew on them right away you will
definitely lose it too
two out of five
[Applause]
we're getting closer to the finale
this is pistachio flavor
that's more interesting i like these
these are good
they're better than the other chocolate
ones but they're still three they're
nothing that interesting to me three out
of five
this looks weird
it's like dango looks like it's plum
flavor or something
[Applause]
it's watching
yeah it's not plum sauce that was right
nah
sorry
i'm sorry i'm sure if you get these like
in a shop
they'd be much better but these are not
[Applause]
i give them one
six pack
well i get six pack if i eat keto diet
oh they're gonna suck then
sorry keto fans
yeah
oh my god it's like eating dirt
oh god you suck
oh god they're so bad no
no
stop stop this is offending me
shame isle oh that's bad
oh i missed one
uh choke chocolate chole
oh so full
whoa they're so big
and so light
i like the
huh
yeah
these are great four out of five
[Applause]
3.6
all right
time to try out
oh wow he's really all there huh how do
you even begin on a guy like this
it's not that bad
grill's dry it's been grilled as well
with soy sauce taste honestly it's
better than the salmon it's not even
that bad
it's really [ __ ] too eel yeah damn
this poor squid had a bad time huh all
right not that bad two out of five that
means the winner
the greatest snack
is this one
jagadi
oh it's cheese wooden cheese it's a type
of cheese big cheese cheese reigns
supreme these are the greatest one
with the runner up
with the crunky
and of course my baby
i will always love you the best ice
cream
well maybe that's how you do it best
best chip jagariko
best chocolate crunchy
bad ice cream
jumbo
idiots of all
anyway this is very educational i hope
you learned a lot here today remember
check out the new pewdiepie cases link
in the description
get the big one get the small one get
them all miss mix and match thank you
for watching guys see you in the next
video